[Music]
in contagious divorce no news submitted
by Dave from downtown downtown de l'eau
Dave a writer shares her theory that
divorce is contagious
why are you can catch it like if one
divorced and you want a divorce and
everybody else wants to divorce yeah
I think she's on to something you think
so too yeah because when my friends go
through breakups I feel like they do it
in clusters oh like groups thank you
give me courage to break up right
because then they're able to kind of
reflect on their own relationship and
say hey you know what maybe I can move
on to that's exactly why she know that
really yeah because it is more fun when
everyone else is single because if
you're the only one single and then no
one else is single it's not that fun
it's true yeah but that's not gonna keep
me from not divorcing right I don't care
about everyone else
well I can't in my head go if I get
divorced and other people are gonna get
divorced right somewhere I'm gonna get a
divorce and let there be other divorce
on you [ __ ] right that you don't think
you know you don't think of other people
I gotta get away from this nasty [ __ ]
she's ruining me it plants a seed and it
makes us sort of like okay yeah it acts
as a gauge for our own relationship yeah
exactly
well Laura looks so happy and content
and actualized and she recently left I
don't know I don't think so because it's
like you and I've seen people break up
but were they really close to you look
so this is particularly with a
tight-knit group of friends and I think
it's if you're an independent thinker
you're less prone to be influenced so I
think you guys are probably really
independent thinkers and even if someone
was really close to you like whatever
they do you probably need a valuator you
would actually like compare your
relationship and see how someone that
really are well even if we were spot on
a spiral downwards Bobby and I we're not
leaving each other
furnace spiral down until CC till we
dead kalila are gonna go down with your
scent of burning dead bodies in flames
what do you guys want to die together
he's just my person yeah yeah
doesn't matter it'll show your good
times were happy volatile
that's why chaos but we're both gonna be
sitting Nancy at man we're gonna we're
gonna tell my Louise it off a cliff
driving that's like the most
romantically sad [ __ ] I've ever heard
yeah you know and it's like for me even
if you you know we're not at that close
but if we're not close at all barely
know you
yeah yeah yeah I don't really want
actually I take that back
if you guys don't make it that'll
probably give me the courage to leave
this mess yes I make it no I think I
think there's a lot of validity to that
because it doesn't matter if you're
independent thinkers or not as soon as
someone's in your tribe and in your
circle like you you're like-minded
people that's a user close so of course
kind of going back to what you're saying
and what you're saying that this author
right or whatever is saying is you know
kind of what you just said right now
like if we don't make it then you're
gonna reevaluate whatever you guys have
whatever but it's so funny because I
think be one of the are I read an
article of that it because I'm on a show
about divorce and they said that my show
was bad for society yeah because of that
same thing that it's you can see two
people divorced actually make it work
yeah yeah that's bad for our society or
something I'm like no it's good for
society because I want people to watch
the show you know I want people to keep
watching it so that I have a job you
know not good for me so this writer name
is Beck days she discusses how her
friends or help our friends really
influence our life and she also mentions
the small study that was held over a 32
year period which concluded that you are
75% more likely to get divorced if
someone in your friends therefore has
gotten divorced Wow
seventy-five books said that's powerful
yeah that's some good-ass odds look I
[ __ ] gamble on that if I could gamble
on people's divorce I'd be like anyone
in your group of friends been divorced
within the last year or two they're like
yeah alright I'm [ __ ] betting on that
they're gonna get divorced I'll bet you
get divorced rate anyways right so it's
like roulette
we were collect for instance right
kalila kalila and i were married
you guys are married and we were close
why you guys that divorce Bart would say
to me yeah you know she would he would
seep things into my consciousness to get
me to get divorced that's [ __ ] up
friends I know buddy but like yeah what
the fish doesn't want to be single alone
I mean he needs a winger yeah and there
was like this effect the girl 19 little
titties she's robbing against my face
like this you know she likes the titty
Robin milk went into my eyes whatever
whatever and I'm like I'm sure the
half-heart I go yeah touching yourself
touching my own self yeah while he's
telling you the story
yeah the little little titty in his eyes
right and I'm gonna leave cuz I want the
same thing so it's a I think it's a lot
of like you know and I would say don't
leave her now just come with me next
time and just watch yeah about the
participant watch my adventures and I'm
watching now this little titty in his
little face right rubbing it's his eyes
he's got a big fees yeah yeah and the
milk is squirting toward me doing this
you know I mean right and then and then
I wanted to milk my fish - yeah and then
I divorce her and you cry cuz you miss
her there isn't once it's a verbal
influence I'm fine for like a week and
and you you have nothing to go back home
to but at the end of the day can I say
this I'm an older guy and I've been
single in my 30s and 40s you know and I
and I've said to myself wow it's not fun
being I know what it's like the grass
isn't greener you know like being single
know if you can find somebody right that
complements your situation and and and
you love this person and you're a team
and she has stuff that you know that
drives me crazy yeah and then like a lot
of stuff that's how you know it's real
and night no - that's Ihram so that I
can give it back yeah well she wakes me
up when I'm sleeping because it's 8 p.m.
it's time to get the [ __ ] up though it
doesn't matter I'm sleeping ok and when
I'm sleeping that when the king of
sleeping with the king sleep the slept
nights are coming out all kinds of chaos
is going on all the food is food is
handed to him in bed coffee everything
if they PM sweetie I think it's time I
need my sleep baby
anyway that's a negative thing but I'm
growing up and I'm man enough to go ok
that's for character defects and I'm
doing I'm willing to grow beyond it and
accept it
[Music]
[ __ ] you reflected so sorry G oh yeah
yeah so I know what it's like being
single and he's better being this way
what are my negative things where do we
begin for a couple years I would go out
to the balcony and I would always get
this whiff of urine or ammonia it turns
out that three bathrooms are not enough
for this man that he has his fascination
for collecting urine and it's not like
fresh urine it had been collecting there
for six [ __ ] years someone in a store
that the ammonia had cracked the pail Oh
in a green bucket he didn't want to
clean it I said you need to clean that
ok I'm out in the balcony I'm smoking
cigarettes right I'm soaking cigarette
and I'm pondering ideas I'm creating
ideas in my mind when I'm out there
right all of a sudden you know I had to
pee yeah oh you don't want to go to the
bathroom hear me out
I just lit a cigarette right should I
put this down go inside yeah or should I
peer right here I happy right there
thank you so much fine if it's a urinal
dump it out once in a while he didn't
even want to do it he was so disgusted
because the it was so old that it had
gone a little bit like
brown brown sticky Oh became maple syrup
yeah his this became syrup like
condensed milk carry it this is like a
3:00 in the morning
this giant job because he wouldn't do it
I wouldn't you I refuse to clean that up
you want it out of the balcony then you
clean it Wow sounds logical to me that's
just one just what minor character do
you have and that's how you know that's
real love that they should make movies
about that exactly that should be a
romantic comedy right there yeah yeah
it'd be like 90% men watching that [ __ ]
how about this one then what is it real
but it's real though that's some real
[ __ ] buckets Appy like getting over like
not [ __ ] sweeping them off their feet
or getting annoyed have a [ __ ] child
girls want to watch some fan fan
fantastic boy the guy takes care of
girls yeah that's amazing
do you have like fifty Shades of Grey
type of [ __ ] rather than [ __ ] yeah
yeah but in reality girls don't want
that because they step all over those
kind of weak-ass dudes and then they end
up with guys like us I'm gonna show you
a photo ones that they did I show
picture Bobby put that away
yeah all right gonna show you my pale
[ __ ] leave it for me [ __ ] a pail
[ __ ] is a character defect and it's not
I can't control what my comes out we
showed him hey stop it stop it
Bobby that's so [ __ ] up don't you
[ __ ] do it put it down you're gonna
get in big trouble Bobby so I could
describe it I can describe it though
okay she's a vegetarian now right
so she has pale [ __ ] oh yeah I heard
that from a cabbage taste tester oh you
eat this [ __ ] cabbage as Dookie
turned out white yeah so I go into the
bathroom because I have to think it dump
myself I wash it before
wait you don't flush or what happened
there I just I think I was probably too
busy running ten of his errands that day
she's an animal
[ __ ] this she put it in the toilet bowl
at least yeah this is sophisticated what
the [ __ ] okay it was perfectly
[ __ ] bye no [ __ ] small yeah it was a
see-through I'll buy no [ __ ] no no no no
[ __ ] [ __ ] we're not there why you
know that's a rude all right even you
[ __ ] on our neighbors gardenias do I
take a you know would I pull off oh I'll
show them this shitty day alright tell
me what you're gonna show and then I'll
show this in Utah yeah you tell me what
you to show I love that you guys have
pictures of you know we're gonna have to
give what is it it's when the plumber
took six hours to unclog that's fun
[ __ ] show that chick on a second find
it I have to find it yeah why would you
[ __ ] all the neighbors plant I need to
take a [ __ ] real bad it wasn't my
neighbor's it was another street over
okay so you ran all the way over there
are you drunk driving we're to a Korean
barbecue place and it was all you can
eat I got food poisoning I don't take a
[ __ ] right then and there
yeah I pulled over as a random house I
don't know and [ __ ] on the side of the
[ __ ] wall alright I was wrong on the
wall I spread it open and they sprayed
all over the wall Oh what is the white
what yeah nothing you just left it there
nothing so I just cut it just smears on
your ass yeah I wouldn't just show you
the pool did you not good I don't think
she has a photo no I do I do
I gotta find this it was pretty pale
it's pre pale pool I think yeah so
that's what I got a deal in this
relationship the color mix [ __ ] is a
character defect it's just gonna be that
white so what did you wish it was
Blanchett like Cate Blanchett [ __ ]
here on the inside what the [ __ ] they do
I'm not looking angel Jesus I have some
other photos lady you want to be showing
other photos of what my tampons yeah
[Music]
please just keep running that so thank
you so much for listening it's only yeah
yeah yeah she can't find it have it my
sister has it
we'll do it later well cut it in later
and editing okay I want to live with you
guys sister you guys she's calling her
sister
this has to be I need a rebuttal here so
you go in de can you bring your own [ __ ]
like right now okay thank you bye you
know I love that she doesn't even
question it she doesn't even ask why
what's going on oh she hasn't say that's
uncomfortable the fucked-up part was you
had a massive like you had a collection
of [ __ ] that you've refused to flush for
six days you clogged the toilet and then
you left the San Francisco and you're
like babe call the plumber the plumber
came in and I was he mad cuz I didn't
want him to look at my face and think
that I did that you are in schema yeah I
was like um excuse me yeah I didn't want
him to ever like see my face and say but
you're acting as if that I'm like an
animal and I six mooning goes it was
clogged in the toilet hold on the
picture will speak for itself
all right the picture will wash it it
was clogged so you just shat on top of
the clog like a porta potty yeah party
he thinks the [ __ ] toilet is a porta
potty where's that guy's picture
nobody fifteen minutes man how many
toilets do you have in your house what
we have three toilets okay here we go
okay here we go show us now show my [ __ ]
I'll put full brightness on this so
everyone can go I want to zoom in on it
right I'm gonna do
look at that bats please pass that over
there oh my god show the Editors waiter
this is six days let me see yeah that's
my bad
that's my bad that's my bad must have
smelled like [ __ ] anyway thanks for
watching
[Music]
you